so USANA says Connor needs 180 days
usought is wrong if that ever gets
tested usad is wrong there is exemptions
for Connor McGregor says I'm taking one
of those exemptions Dana's saying we've
got the date set I haven't revealed it
but we haven't set and I'll reveal it
through the ultimate fighter and USANA
said he's not in the pool all of those
things can't be true that's the fight
that I've been waiting to see McGregor
versus USANA that's the fight that I
really want to see but ustad is not
going to like how this one turns out you
better read their own paperwork dude do
we know what the exemption entails
exactly this is where osada looks at one
Clause that says it's a retirement
Clause meaning if you leave the pool we
don't want you to go on a steroid
holiday we're gonna bring it back we're
going to keep you in there a while
normally it's two months but if you
retire and come back we need you for six
months to make sure in case you got
something you got it out of your system
but the effects and the residuals are
still there that's the Clause that
they're turning to there's another
Clause but it says in extenuating
Circumstance the organization can bypass
the entire protocol